jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video das heutige bliebe
das zwei teilen bestehen zwar als erstes
eine app oder als zweites erzähle ich
euch eine ziemlich verrückte story die
mir zusammen mit luca in köln passiert
ist also bleibt auf jeden fall dran und
los geht's so leute lampe gehen wir mal
mit der app und zwar nicht bestens
angehauen deshalb steht hier jetzt
irgendwo werbevideo ob ich nicht lust
habe das neue spiel von ihnen an zu
zocken und zwar ist das best fields
forever ihr seht ihr jetzt hier mal so
das logo eingeblendet bestens aber ist
das dritte spiel aus der spielreihe und
hat zwar die gleiche geschichte und die
gleichen teams bzw charaktere ich aber
trotzdem eine komplett neue version des
spiels weil vom gameplay her sich circa
alles verändert hat ich habe
lustigerweise bevor die mich an gehauen
haben das alte bestens gezockt und ich
würde sagen wir schauen mal zusammen in
das neue spiel rein das spiel
funktioniert so ihr seht schon hier
tipps zum schlagen und das ist
eigentlich so ziemlich alles was wir
machen ist das ist also echt echt simpel
aber es macht mir viel spaß also ihr
kämpft euch quasi durch die schnecken
weil schnecken sind ja
bekanntlicherweise die großen feinde von
den fans und ihre haut die schnecken
kaputt einfach nacheinander
aber wenn ihr jetzt mal hier an die
seite schaut es gibt auch so tnt fester
und ihr könnt ihr einfach boom in die
luft jagen und dann werden auch die
schnecken die euch im weg stehen
schnellstmöglich in die luft gejagt und
diese art von spiel nennt sich click
abenteuer spiel weil ihr klickt und es
ist abenteuerlich weil ich durch die
ganze schnecken welt kämpfen falls ihr
es bock bekommen habt auf das spiel das
wird es ab dem 22
oktober an apps und in google places tor
geben und ist kostenlos erhältlich alle
weiteren infos dazu findet ihr noch mal
unten in der beschreibung und ich würde
sagen dass war es soweit von der app wir
kommen jetzt zur story die ich in köln
erlebt habe es trifft ganz gut dass
jetzt gerade die app vorgestellt habe
weil so ein ganzes video hätte man nicht
füllen können mit der story aber es hat
sich wie folgt zugetragen ich war
letztens bei luca in köln wir haben
zusammen ein paar videos aufgenommen und
gezählt wobei gechillt er nicht weil wir
so richtig viele video ideen hatten
richtig wenig zeit alles machen wollten
wir haben videos zusammen aufgenommen
und ich musste dann weiter zum nächsten
termin den nicht an köln hatte so und
weil luca auch los muss seit er gesagt
komm ich bringe ich noch zu bauen wir
sind zusammen losgelaufen haben uns halt
auf den weg zur bahn gemacht wenn sie
neben luca gelaufen und habe nebenbei am
handy die bahnverbindung gecheckt oder
sowas zu unterhalten
ich guck so nach oben habe einfach mal
kurz vom handy den kopf gehoben sein
okay da läuft und frau auf mich zu und
dann sind da noch ein paar andere leute
und so guckt wieder runter aufs handy
und plötzlich aus heiterem himmel ich
überhaupt nichts geblickt fliegt mir
gegen meine hand man sieht sie nicht
mehr so wirklich ich hatte so einen ganz
leichten wie soll ich sagen so eine so
leichte schürfungen hier liegt mir eine
voll gefüllte flasche gegen das
handgelenk ich guckte von meinem handy
hoch in vollkommen verfehlt was
überhaupt abgeht und dann war da diese
frau die gerade eben auf mich zugelaufen
war
die war irgendwie so ja keine ahnung 30
35 oder so und hebt gerade die flasche
auf die mir eben an mein handgelenk
geflogen ist und ich hab's halt
überhaupt nicht gecheckt und mich
gewundert und dachte so okay wir
bestimmt irgendwo erklärung dafür haben
oder so vielleicht ist sie aus der hand
gefallen aber es hat mich halt echt
somit mit einer relativ großen bucht
sage ich mal getroffen und dann ist
diese frau da nur schild irgendwie sowas
gibt die flasche auf und sagt dann so
und das ok ascom entschuldigung oder tut
mir leid die flasche aus der hand
gerutscht
oder was weiß ich irgendwo logische
erklärung also sagte ich wollte
eigentlich die andere hand treffen und
dann nimmt sie so die flasche und
straftäter mit gegen meine andere hand
ich verstehe es wirklich nicht also es
war so eine absurde situation weil
erstens sie ist eine frau ich würde
keine frau angreifen oder sowas und ich
würde auch jedoch kein mann angegriffen
der mich abgeworfen hat aber irgendwie
macht dass die situation irgendwann ein
bisschen komisch weil ich habe in dem
moment sie ist dann direkt weiter
gelaufen habe ich nicht gesagt hey was
soll das oder so wobei ich hab so gesagt
so was irgendwie was einfach voll
verwundert war
aber jetzt meine frau ich hätte mich
nicht mit ihr bauen können
sie war einfach so optischen jemand wo
ich echt nicht damit gerechnet hätte
dass ihr mich irgendwie an greift also
mit der flasche abwirft habe eingesehen
dass sie dass sie irgendwie wohl noch
pfandflaschen gesammelt hat und
wahrscheinlich war sie irgendwie
betrunken oder so aber es war eine
wirklich komische situation also ich war
so perplex und dann habe ich erstmal
habe ich erst mal luca und guckt man so
was war das gerade und er fängt an zu
lachen ich auch also ich habe jetzt ja
keinen bleibenden schaden davon getragen
oder so aber es war einfach so eine
absurde situation habe ich noch so
umgeschaut und standen also leute so im
alter von mir und lukas ein paar meter
weiter und haben mich auch so gut dass
ich es wieder so blick und herren habe
ich auch angefangen zu lachen aber die
situation war wirklich komisch so eine
frau wirft mich einfach ab ich kannte
sie nicht also ich habe sie nie zuvor
gesehen was lernen wir daraus nehmen
keine drogen nehmen können druck
ich habe mir dann über diese ganze
geschichte noch viel mehr gedanken
gemacht als nötig wäre eigentlich also
viel glas ok hättest du dir etwas sagen
sollen oder so aber die situation gegen
einfach so schnell vorbei dass ich das
ehrlich gesagt vollkommen überfordert
waren paar abschließende worte für
dieses video passt auf vor
flaschenwerfer damit scherz man duckt
euch falls irgendjemand gefüllten
flasche so aus oder so dann druckt
schnell und taucht unter der flasche
hinweg und ansonsten bleibt sicher ja
das war vom heutigen video